se trata de un territorio que fue
adjuntado al territorio de la unión
soviética como la consecuencia del pacto
molotov-ribbentrop concluido en
1939 y con la invasión conjunta
soviética y de alemania nace en europa y
este territorio durante los tiempos de
la unión soviética
tenía una base militar muy importante
soviética en la parte europea cuando se
acababa la unión soviética
precisamente la población de esta región
de habla rusa
intenta separarse de moldavia y este
intento de separación fue apoyado de
manera prácticamente abierta por moscú
en el comienzo de la década 90 se
firmaron un acuerdo que transformó en la
parte caliente del conflicto en un
conflicto congelado
hasta ahora realmente hubo muy pocos
aquí acciones en esta zona que está
regulado además por un acuerdo firmado y
al comienzo de la década 90 sin embargo
en el contexto de la guerra en ucrania
este territorio vuelve
estratégico tanto para rusia como para
europa porque está ubicado precisamente
con la frontera con la unión europea si
usted nos ha hablado ya de la guerra en
los años 90 y la posterior separación
con bondad había desde entonces rusia ya
cuenta con tropas en este territorio y
en 2006 se votó por una independencia
que nadie reconoce qué intenciones tiene
rusia en este territorio
en bueno roussel tiene presencia
legítima en este territorio precisamente
porque existe un acuerdo de la década de
90 lo que pasa que hay unas
interpretaciones distintas como pasa con
algunos otros documentos como los
famosos acuerdos de miel que entonces
hay unas interpretaciones distintas por
parte de monda bien por parte de rusia
rusia insiste que este acuerdo le da
permiso mantener las tropas rusas en
este territorio mientras moldava insiste
que el acuerdo estaba estipulado que las
tropas rusas deberían ser retiradas y
hay algo que hay que tener en cuenta
porque en esta población de este líquido
donde está cuál ser pública
independiente votó ya en un referéndum a
favor de unificarse con el territorio
ruso quiere ser parte de rusia y esto
ahora puede ser utilizado por moscú como
una justificación de comenzar dar un
apoyo mucho más significativo a esta
región de montaña
clark y entonces este nuevo anuncio qué
implicaciones podría tener para los
vínculos entre moldavia y transnistria y
podría convertirse este territorio en
una nueva crimea
en un principio yo creo que rusia ahora
está muy ocupada en ucrania y
posiblemente no va a tener los recursos
suficientes en este momento para poder
hacer algo allá más allá de unas
retóricas de unas narrativas de apoyar a
los rusos en el mismo equipo de
retóricas que nosotros estuvimos
observando antes del comienzo en la
guerra en ucrania lo que también hay que
tener en cuenta quien las partes que
estuvieron actuando como garantes del
acuerdo del comienzo de la década 90
eran los rusos o los ucranianos y los
ucranianos ahora ha retirado sus
observadores entonces el único realmente
la única fuerza que hasta allá son los
rusos y esto les da una ventaja en el
desarrollo de cualquier escenario que
moscú puede considerar útil para ellos
para los rusos en este momento